So to cover the optimization philosophy briefly, we want to be thinking about optimization throughout the entire project
It's no good starting a project and throwing all the content in and then getting towards the end of the project
Say you're at the last 90% and then figuring out how you need to optimize it
You need to almost optimize on the go and also when starting your project
Figure out the the target platforms target frame rates that you want to be hitting
Ahead of time and it allows you to make some
Optimizations on the way and then also throughout this course, we'll be talking about just good content pipelines
You can follow with your your content whether it be on the mesh side the material side
Whatever it might be. You can be making these optimizations as you go on ensuring your project is hitting
Framerate, so you really want to be talking about
optimization throughout the entire length of the project and
Constantly putting checks in place to ensure you're hitting the target frame rate on the desired platform